I definitely had some some feared rashes
in college I don't think it was
something we talked about I think we all
suffered in silence when I first grew my
beard out I didn't really know like how
to maintain it I can say that it took on
a smell of its own as well and to the
point where my wife would not kiss me we
also found a live animal in my beard one
there was a dragonfly
there was a live dragonfly in my my
friend that was the rock bottom I think
when it's like a one-time makeout you're
not gonna tell them they should grow
your beard a little bit or just shave
the whole thing off you're just gonna go
with the flow wait no no I could say
honey shave your beard ah early injuries
I think there was definitely some
chafing
I guess my skin's not super sensitive
but during the winter time is when I
would break that into rashes for a
minute and it's usually like at the
beginning like right after two or three
days after shaving that it's that the
worst of the haunts it grows longer it's
much easier
definitely I think the longer beard is
better like a short beard is Havoc it
hurts everyone and on them I think was
when the hair is really short and if a
sticks out that's when like that kind of
hurts
you're like an extended lip kiss like
this I'm knockout and just like just I
think when it's that length I just know
that like this too shall pass
plus I like looking I love you but I
like looking at that more than this but
this feels better so it's like you know
what is it me neither one no
compromising I think it was scratchy
back the first time that he grew it a
long time ago there just wasn't really a
market for men's products back then I
think what's worse than the rash is when
it gets is when the beard grows the
moustache grows just over the lip I
always feel like I'm slurping it and I'm
like
I have never had like one be a mustache
other than that one time I think it's
important to keep the beard like off
your mouth
that's true you don't want to be lifting
it up yeah so above the lip is a good
one
regular conditioning I think that's
really key having it smell great and
keeping it soft as long as it has a
really nice texture and a good smell I
think you'll pretty much tolerate
anything